[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember so you don't have to hard to
believe that there was a time when Ryan
Reynolds was seen as the kiss of death
for superhero movies he had hugely
disappointing films that pissed off both
audiences and diehard fans it wasn't
until he brilliantly pushed to replay
one of those disappointments with
Deadpool that he elevated himself into
comic book legend drew bringing the
character exactly what he deserved and
smashing box-office records which is
good because I think if he left things
the way they were with Green Lantern
Shaq would have gotten more street cred
based on the DC comic book Green Lantern
knows one of the big heroes that joined
the Justice League so making a movie
about him in 2011 seemed to make sense
however this film was so botched it so
unexcited then that only did they not
bother to give him his own sequel but as
far as we know they're not including
this version and the DC EU it's ugly
it's dull it's downright unpleasant it's
a green mess and to emphasize in
contrast how bad this is I brought a
special guest chimichangas yeah
that's right I have Bryan Reynolds most
beloved comic book interpretation
talking about his most hated comic book
interpretation you got a unicorn it
really could use a unicorn his wild
comedic antics will no doubt add a lot
to this review where the boobies boobies
let's take a look at green lantern with
our special guest Deadpool Marine
Orton's sucked that it did billions of
years ago a race of immortals the
guardians of the universe okay a DC
property talking about the guardians of
the universe yeah that doesn't make you
want to say something Marvel character
oh that's my dick psycho I'm Deadpool
I'm Deadpool chimichangas why don't you
go over there for a while I was gonna do
that anyway cuz I'm Deadpool I do what I
like we're calling being a lot funnier
than that so it looks like there's
peacekeepers throughout the galaxy known
as the Green Lantern's magic heroes with
magic rings I will kill you if you even
have all those threats to the core ever
faced the gravest of parallax okay Devon
album soul was capable of capturing and
imprisoning this Beach yeah is it me or
does it look like the universe sneezed
criolla pains and then pissed on it with
five different alien urines this all
looks hideous
oh no we're back in fat for sex
you will not adventure evil on me again
I'd say these astronauts came across
Marvin the Martian but truth be told
Marvin the Martian looks more realistic
this is where we keep the unrendered
Mars Attacks effects the CG is awful
this is 2011 I keep expecting Michael
Jordan and Bugs Bunny to pop out two
minutes into this effects movie and it
already shows it sucks at effects
what am I even looking at here
Megatron Schlag Dovan tarantara is dead
the planets inhabitants the Guardian
society bond you know I feel like I'm
watching expired jello mold to act in
dirty glasses of piss
it's amazing how unappealing this all
looks
hmm I don't remember this scene from
injustice - oh hell it's an insult to
compare it to that these effects are
like a flashlight let Superman 64 prey
they develop Pixar there we come across
our lead Hal Jordan played by Reynolds
partaking in the most overused of
introduction tropes doc I'm late for
school gentlemen stop geeky guy in every
movie
so Helen another pilot are supposed to
outsmart two AI fighter jets to
demonstrate whether or not the
technology is ready for combat
sound check by this is cool right gotta
love that military technology that's on
par with a Tron game
radar says we need more quarters heel
smarts the AI Jets but not before having
a flashback to his incredibly cliched
childhood even warm
things really do fizzle though as he
remembers what happened to his father
shortly after you're not secure you dad
let's just say it's my job god oh my god
I'm scared
I'm so scared SC AR IDI scared
he had his fireproof jacket he would
warm for me so what can one say but
maverick I thought this was a dogfight I
was under the impression the objective
was to win the objective was to show
what the Sabres could do in actual
combat you didn't have to make that
point front of the commander of air
force acquisition Carol yeah any other
overused lines you want to throw in
there your fires too late wow this movie
really hits every lame in the book
doesn't it Deadpool what what is this
I'm wearing something silly how does it
connect to anything that's going on it's
stupid
therefore badass following any of your
humor cuz I'm dead bull okay I really
recall him being funnier but as boss
Carol says he can't quit he's just
grounded gunney room hey that's funnier
than the actual funny lines they have
watch your back that's impossible
I also would have accepted spinning
around looking at your back to be yogurt
a burger he goes to visit his brother
and nephew who are both angry and
concerned about him are you scared
my job not to be I'm glad you're okay
well good because you literally have no
other scenes in the movie family it's
there no idea how to segue in three two
in most scenarios Ryan Reynolds in a
hamster ball would be the dumbest part
of the movie he's taken to the crashed
alien ship where the aliens rings
summons him
Reynolds has a look on his face like oh
my god is this kind of movie I did not
know what I was signing up for
hey do that Oh looks like you better
call nine one this guy spaceship yeah
it's real it's real okay have you
trolley turning to film off and all
again let's go we'll probably realize
there's no reason to keep this a secret
meanwhile kept intent abysmal discusses
what's happened with thee not even close
to looking interested Council four of my
lantern brothers killed in evidence of
two worlds how can they hear him right
all right why do we have chairs so hot
cuz from a distance we can take his pink
ass seriously that we can't after that
he'll is told he can use the dead aliens
ring as long as he recites the oath to
what else the Green Lantern pledge
allegiance to a lantern to infinity and
beyond by the power of Grayskull wow
that last part wasn't scripted he just
realized they pay for copyright
licensing on to weak-ass jokes it
finally works though as the oath comes
to him psychically thus he is tapped
into an unknown alien society that has
protected the universe for eons and eons
a whole new universe of responsibility
is open up to him I do want to get a
drink yeah we can do that yeah that's
pretty you totally get the epic weight
and scale of this story the contract
isn't quite that yet you know half this
movie is like an orange magic how you
cross your eyes and uncross I mean you
can see orange figures in front of other
orange figures it's like an open loop a
cut of Footloose but magic Listerine is
added again as it teleports him across
the universe okay this could redeem a
few points if he has to serve on a star
this captain by Tim Allen
[Music]
so yeah like a booger flying through
chocolate milk mix this is not as
visually mind-blowing as you would hope
to quote Bart Simpson the universe is so
boring we've scanned him there's no
discernible charm in his performance
yeah let's play the game of who made a
mistake saying yes to this film that's a
short round yeah just to clarify this is
the origin of the sidekick right you're
gonna team them up with someone more
intimidating like Kevin Hart have you
concluded admiring news oh oh I'm sorry
I thought we were gonna have a sequence
there we had the music the movement I
guess that's just what the film
hiccuping looks like general Akbar here
is named hamare played by Geoffrey Rush
who's asked really the only sensible
question in the entire film what's with
all the green green is the color of will
the Guardians harnessed will because
it's the strongest source of energy in
the universe but ugly Reds and stained
mustard yellows too draining sewage
Green this whole movie is like being
trapped in a shit stain stop light from
3600 lanterns each of the sector just as
fast how come none of them wear fake
masts it wasn't impressive enough as
they are sunburned Stephen Colbert comes
out to tell them all about the bad news
for learned--and brothers were killed by
an enemy called parallax that's the name
of a laxative right they can't actually
be a frightening title so he'll of
course is trained in the ways of the
lantern and much like this movie hell
can't understand the logic of being
green wit your will turns thought into
reality
to master the ring we must learn to
focus your will and create what you see
in your mind the Rings limits are only
what you can imagine you know let me rip
a few pages from the Empire Strikes Back
about the force that the ring will
inform you where there is an imminent
threat did I mention I'm an incredible
liar Wow this is Kilowog voiced by a
clearly half-awake Michael Clarke Duncan
welcome to ring sling in 101 I'm gonna
hit you into your withers dog next
lesson he's not gonna play fair never
let your guard down loser film it early
recording this while they're putting the
makeup on me for Planet of the Apes I'm
not bringing my aid material to this
he's taught that the ring can create
whatever he wants to will alone
including the ancient weapon of cocktail
swords to keep cherries in your drink I
was a great warrior salt his memory by
wearing his ring you will never earn the
title broccoli brother I'm done he's
right I'm only human the ring never
makes mistake it so yeah this seems
embarrassingly bad in visuals comedies
storytelling and character if only
somebody who was supposed to be the
complete opposite of that would
commentate on this with me
look I'm dancing on all of your favorite
movies well it's okay I remember because
Jimmy Chuck the unicorn you didn't even
take it I do what I like Apple Jacks
okay seriously what am I missing here
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so houses drew this shit he's going back
to earth where it's normal but of course
that's not true because earth is home of
Peter Sarsgaard he plays a scientist
named Hector who's called in to examine
the crashed alien life-form but he gets
infected by something that gives him
incredible powers like combining William
Shatner and John Malkovich into one
performance many of these little
critters that we've been calling
bacteria weren't bacteria at all they
were an entirely different type bunny
starts to tap into the mind of the
average viewer watching this film
Michael
so yes you'd expect this is gonna be our
villain of the film I know you're just
as excited as I was because that's who I
want to see a superhero fight the guy
who looks both ways before entering a
porno theater is it even worth feeling
let down by this point get used to
disappointment
okay what would he expect though he's
the son of Tim Robbins a guy so dumb he
doesn't even put a combination on his
safe amount of sub-committee it was you
that's why they chose me it's the way
the world works sees an opportunity but
it presents itself poor guy has strings
pull to get in positions of power and
now that's a tragic valid story let's
begin a tragic house Reynolds doing
Oh mr. Reynolds action yeah yeah one
more glad you could make it son Frank
that's a little surprised I got the
invite you know I always say there are
thinkers in this world and there are
doers whom you are one of the doers huh
Tim Robbins both complimented and
insulted you at the same time it's like
when he makes a political speech
[Applause]
many of you might be wondering why they
showed him sit that drink in such a
weird way so how is uncomfortable at the
party but things get even more socially
awkward when the helicopter crashes
okay this is the mask right a green guy
you laugh at every time you see him
using cartoons to save the day it's a
different take to say the least but
still I'll take it over this sequel well
good to know over halfway through the
movie the Green Lantern finally save
somebody but now without being
rightfully called out I'm lameness a
racetrack
yeah hmm that's the best you could come
up with your first big appearance you
sure we're not watching the writing
session for this flick I want to see it
you ready to have your mind blown yeah
after this I'm somehow gonna be Deadpool
twice did you break it over I didn't
break it okay it's just juice sergeant
what you just saw should have been
edited out our apologies I know right
pretty lame huh Green Twizzlers that's
what they went with but he's not the
only one green with Alia
evening ma'am didn't get a chance to say
goodbye are you okay is my fake voice
fake enough you saved my life
Yusuf's all of our lives how how I died
how did you know as me what do you know
my whole life I've seen you naked you
don't think I would recognize you cuz I
can see your cheekbones well the movie
was dumb enough to go with that for a
dance oh yeah Christ I'm shocked it took
you this long to figure it out hey watch
this I'm a totally different person now
so now we have the classic superhero
movie attempt at romance in spider-man
we had the famous kiss upside down and
it's Superman that Fame is flying
through the sky sequence now we have a
guy who can make anything come to life
very cool what are you gonna do with it
okay so at the party how did you make
that big green ramp thing anything I see
him like mine like I can create you're
just gonna sit there and talk aren't you
oh my god are you kidding me are you
freaking kidding me you can literally do
anything anything you can write a
Pegasus to the tunnel of love while the
water in time is and you sit on a roof
hello
did they fly in Superman it would have
been so much more romantic if he just
walked up to Lois and said let's get
McDonald's okay but Sarsgaard who's
turning into Jabba the Harry Knowles is
trying to figure out the next step in
becoming a sky-high character
[Music]
I'm here to ask if you located the scene
where I found out where you are
you're so pathetic I'll just knock
myself out for you you really are the
pities gross superheroes escapes though
allowing hell to go ask the Guardians
for help you know we were saying on
earth you say I'm only human usually
after we make a really bad movie so kind
of confusing reasoning he'll ask them if
he can fight the evil alone before they
use a weapon that could destroy other
lives in the process they agree
resulting in him immediately almost
destroying another life in the process
she's beautiful isn't she
I loved her from the moment I first saw
her
Oh apparently that was a thing you know
at this point you could say he turned
evil because he didn't get his oil
change no one really cares anymore he
hands over the ring to save her but how
still has control and knocks him out
this somehow releases parallax onto the
world
bullshit face I've come to bargain tits
sauron's less impressive brother moron
so smoke turds start eating up the town
but not to worry Green Lantern has a
catapult and a spring oh come on you
couldn't have his bill on backwards
after getting hit Green Lantern lures
him into space where like I've been
saying the Looney Tunes movies have
better effects as he puts the ass in
asteroids look he's making to chance
it's like he's conquering his fears even
though he could just turn into a giant
fist and punch it what did that take so
long so the great evil is defeated I
have no idea why only he could do it but
to my credit I don't think the movie
does either and he says goodbye to his
girlfriend I mean I want another acting
job after this and the less I'm seen
around you with that mask the higher
that possibility will be but there's one
other big surprise I think was supposed
to be a surprise
yeah you totally forgot I was in this
tin Zhu Green Lantern yay what a bundle
of fun that was not I had any help from
my pointless coal reviewer knock-knock
I'm not playing orange I didn't even say
who's there orange it glad I'm awesome
that's it hyper hi critic can you tell
me what's going on here I thought having
Deadpool in my review would be amazing
but he's just an unused weap oh that's
not Deadpool that's not no that's
cosplaying asshole Deadpool you know one
of those guys at a convention who just
because he's wearing a Deadpool costume
thinks that he's instantly funny and he
do no wrong I'm gonna judge really hot
chicks and act like I have a chance to
get with them oh that's why he's so
insufferable you see I thought something
that was so clever and timeless would be
represented here but instead I've just
got an imitation that has no idea what
made the original good you can play
clips over this that's the idea
it looks like the hero has the details
like the hero but it's just a pale
imitation of the hero ugly unimaginative
not charming and inspires no joy
whatsoever all of this was a complete
waste of time
boobies I must have boobies Oh back off
you pervert
no Critic it's okay what you want him to
touch you no but it's his choice to do
it if he wants really yeah
hi he made me spoil the surprise Wow I
left the ring at home but no he'll let
me steal why this tickles digits hi
coucher we're not getting any younger
would you do me the honor I'm wearing
this ring finger on your ring finger I
love your iron stabs buddy
Mazel Tov I guess come on let's get more
smashed than his golf today small just
because you dress like that pool doesn't
mean you're dead cool and just because
you dress like Green Lantern doesn't
mean you're Green Lantern represent
think it out and do the right thing I'm
not as dowser critic and I'm gonna kick
him a bit more because it's fun
[Music]
[Applause]
watch your back that's impossible
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and if you've been keeping
track of these you know once again I
don't need to show any pictures or
footage because if you've been watching
the news you know that a giant
earthquake has hit Mexico recently as a
tip in 19th it hit and it has cost so
many lives and it's destroyed so many
homes and just left people with
literally nothing and it's one of those
things where it's been a tough couple
months here it looks like I mean so many
people have been going through so much
unfortunate stuff but that's one of the
reasons we do this you know as when
stuff like this happens so we have a
link below that you can give to the
money go straight helping people that
have been affected by this terrible
disaster and it's it's such a shame it's
such a tough like I said couple of
months and mainly the last month where
all this has been happening and however
bad things are for you you know there's
always people in worse situations and
this is definitely a worse situation
people have lost so much so definitely
go click on the link whatever amount you
have even though it's just a buck or
whatever I mean go ahead every little
bit is gonna make a big difference
definitely go and open your heart thank
you so much
you